China has insisted that investigating
the origins of covert 19 should be left
to the scientists but those scientists
do not include the World Health
Organization according to its
representative here is the WTO doing
work right now into the origins of the
virus we know that some national
investigation is happening but at this
stage we have not been invited to join
we are expecting to get in the in the
near future briefing on where that is
and to discuss possible collaboration so
you still haven't been invited by the
Chinese authorities to take part up till
now we have not had the invitation no I
mean that must be frustrating I it's one
tries not to get emotional one tries to
simply follow the process is there a
good reason not to include the WHI at
this stage from our point of view no and
any investigation should include the two
labs that handled viruses in Wuhan the
whou has visited one but not received
any of its logs from all available
evidence
w-h-o colleagues that in our three level
system are convinced that the origins
are in Wuhan and that it is a naturally
occurring not a manufactured virus
doubts have also been raised about the
reliability of China's numbers in early
January the official number of Korea
virus cases stayed unchanged for nearly
two weeks before sharply rising we only
know what what China is reporting to us
is it likely that there were only 41
cases for that period of time I would
think not
is that a matter of difficulty in
finding were they were they getting
their act together is it a question of
definition
I cannot speculate but it would have
been that during during that period
obviously some growth would have been
happening
never two weeks it simply stays the same
I mean that seems to like a belief it is
unlikely that
that with an epidemic of this nature
that it stays at 41 exactly and the key
question for the whole of January was
whether the virus could be transmitted
human to human as soon as the WHI
arrived in Wuhan on January 20th
they had their answer the health care
worker was simply volunteered the moment
we entered the fever clinic we were
shown around this at that point
makeshift system that had been set up
and we simply asked it as one of the
first questions and we got it
immediately we've got that answer in
that case they said they had had two
case two health care workers that were
infected answers like that however long
in coming were crucial for transparency
right now china isn't giving them at
least not to the WHI Tom Cheshire Sky
News Beijing